all right they want their event house
good beer welcome tonight three of I
forgot the title but it's up there
dungeon keeper dungeon nightmares there
you go it hides in the shadows just like
I do when I'm taking a pill oh hello
loading ship whoa well that was easy
probably over the game is to find the
artifact and I spawn on it fantastic now
we just have to find the exit
I wouldn't excuse me I would I don't
know I don't [ __ ] out yeah sorry
being scared makes me burp I can't help
it
alright so the dawning changed a little
bit we're okay I'm hoping it's up there
cuz that up there looks suspicious I'm
gonna use a candle just to lit the mood
make it all knives Hey
oh hey you try to grab me again you
touch me again and I will slap your
titties awesome sorry did you make him
do that
no well [ __ ] you yeah damn that [ __ ]
noise doors can be loud man should try
to oil that [ __ ] or something no I'm
hello I'm a little cook oh hello hey
fancy meeting you here
it's been it's been great had a lot of
fun tonight
ah you know 1 min ago by that's too
[ __ ] bad because I'm fat and I'm
brought together way run run running
running running what the [ __ ] is up
that [ __ ] is after ray oh my god you're
I'm not your senpai or what - fine
what's that hurt we're fine we're fine
that was no wait outside ok we're dead
we're dead we're absolutely dead
well I we're a lot of things ok I don't
know we're shorting his cat at the
moment I don't know how to explain it
it's a paradox that I don't even know
how to do but it works in this game in a
little little favor yo what's up barrels
kind of [ __ ] see you later hater
skater hey miss Gaynor
see you later barrel earlier this gate I
don't even know okay cool
why am I even loading these I don't need
that [ __ ]
driving around and me gonna kinda change
in my life I um I don't understand why
you have to touch me all right that's
great when you're dark dark oh man oh
man you gotta do something Hey all right
that's a really annoying sound the
accent yes yes buddy
- bye-bye bye-bye boom boom
[ __ ] yeah I'm on a roll baby girl that
was easy
oh my god so easy it's gonna be so easy
oh my god the easiest game I have ever
played you woke up at 2:46 five percent
of the gold found I think that's a win
Edgar get out of my face
do you want to play the game are you
shokyo come here
Oh jump she'll be just shook up know
what's right cute Chuck here you want
food right well I don't have anything
[ __ ] to go away night for can't wait I
was a high five Casey missed em all
right yeah find every secret chest if
you can I'm not gonna do that
don't give a [ __ ]
there's mummified zambese alright a lot
of toilet paper has been done to get
that look and that's spooky man I
remember gotten random memory in my
brain I remember when there when I was a
kid and we went to Halloween parties and
I thought it was sooo scary to dress up
its [ __ ] something's behind the door
well [ __ ] what am I gonna do about must
stop it I'm telling a story and they
were like too scary so I didn't want to
I didn't tell my mom that it was a
Halloween party so that I didn't have to
dress up as anything but then she found
out in the last minute so she took one
of the sheets okay dude I'm telling a
story and then but it was some fun uh um
add for a stroll are we that's great
come on babe alright um and she cut you
know the cut the holes in the sheets and
you look like a ghost so I took it and I
promised that I would wear it but I
never did
true story probably great story great
great great story probably one of my
favorite stories ever of all time after
Moby Dick maybe because it has nothing
actually let's stay on subject here
death and suffering hello there
gentlemen
that maneuver so far now ain't assange a
platitude look many at a 4/5 done okay I
just seen my artifact and then I'll be
gone I'll be gone I'll be gone
papi got ya miss me when I'm gone you're
gonna miss me by my hair you're gonna
miss me why do I sing that [ __ ] song
that's not know I'd see you again
I'm getting tired of your [ __ ] man oh
whoa whoa never seen that [ __ ] try
something out next time
here comes yeah that's right slapping
titty I warned him hey don't look at me
like that it's not cruel I warned him
[ __ ] it's so awkward okay
whoa the scares get a little old when
you've seen them like five times and
it's identical they work very well in
the beginning I'm better not Jeff Lana
okay just dubstep dubstep stop it upset
you should not have come here
well oh [ __ ] what the [ __ ] now goddamn
or deficit shut up
oh no that [ __ ] sound is not okay man
it's always on the X okay I can't run
it's so bad please something bad man
it's not my [ __ ] fault your bad it's
not my fault oh god no oh god she's so
[ __ ] good just cute just give me the
artifact I don't understand what I did
to you this noise is not okay it's not
okay I can't have no mission buzz Oh for
[ __ ] sake how does she keep knowing
where oh my [ __ ] god oh god he's fat
again oh oh my jesus [ __ ] christ that
is so terrifying
alright so we found the exit somewhere
down there we just need the artifact oh
my god Oh
I made income just by my sheer presence
I'm so [ __ ] hot [ __ ] couldn't handle
me god damn if amber lamps out up I'm a
donkey I was [ __ ] actually ah
let's carry more than he probably [ __ ] I
just started froze like a little [ __ ]
try to use telekinesis to say I'll
replay for you
I really would like that [ __ ]
artifact man oh my god oh my god okay we
haven't checked those two rooms down
there they could be very well down there
I thinks I especially think that since
ice since I can't [ __ ] talk okay so
we checked every room but [ __ ] one
which probably means that we missed it
somewhere which is really bad if we did
please oh the [ __ ] is your problem
I seriously how can I not have found it
please oh my god they always was so
close to it - [ __ ] you I'm out of here
[ __ ] oh oh I think would actually
find it I'm gonna [ __ ] a duck man look
at that 100% hundred percent hundred
percent notes I guess I miss a few notes
she's waiting for me
great great fan can't wait to meet you a
five six seven eight welcome back to
dungeon nightmares shut up [ __ ] don't
be a [ __ ] it's gonna be either alright
so we're back and it's fun love it
please be the artifact good job that's a
fun great way to start a video no
artifact either great hi great to meet
you don't you ever spray badges what
oh you sprayed [ __ ] oh my god
oh my god oh no I'm gonna dead end I
think oh no please still come in here Oh
what are you doing why me
shut up I don't like you oh come on stop
being fat man ed guy I can't handle it
ain't [ __ ] oh my god she's coming
for [ __ ] sake what is this [ __ ]
stop I don't have any folks oh my god
so apparently this dungeon grows
stronger every day and if you die you
have to restart everything so dying is
bad and if you're on our breath
apparently you can't [ __ ] but some funny
he'll bet this job la BISE Iravan a
scaffold root output Chaplin victim oh
my god why would they do that
haha yeah more candles seven isn't
enough
I need a candle on Oh gold tune that
won't slow me down maybe that's why I'm
so fat
alright let's just get out of here I
hear someone eating over there I want to
go there okay I get a lot of more stuff
now something a little bit alone there
you go mark in the [ __ ] Medavoy oh
sorry didn't know you could hear me
we're gonna have to go in the crackling
place favorite place Oh oh my god she
ate my eyes out maja was I supposed to
know that
don't you dare we start from the
beginning I will pee on you oh my god oh
you [ __ ] you [ __ ] you no [ __ ] way
hope you guys enjoy this episode leave a
like if you did I always appreciate it
what am i doing pew pew shooting you
with kisses love you brother
haha